Merci for the shower.
-La douche.
-What?
The shower is la douche.
Oh.
Well,
I had a wonderful
douche.
Ugh, this can't
be happening. Come on!
Sorry, I...
I thought this was
my apartment. Fifth floor?
This is the fourth floor.
Fifth floor.
Right.
Oh, jeez.
I did it again.
I'm really so sorry.
Emily, do you want
to live in my apartment?
Come on, I mean,
even you have to admit
that the floor number here
makes absolutely no sense.
I have to get to work,
but, um, I promise I won't
bang on your door again.
No problem.
Bang anytime.
No, here,
the customer is never right.
Maybe I'll educate
the chef a little bit
about customer service.
You think
you're gonna change
the entire French culture
by sending back a steak?
Gabriel!
Emily.
Hi, can you come talk
to my plumber?
It's an emergency.
Good morning, Gabriel.
How are you today?
Asleep.
Thank you for asking.
I was having
a very nice dream,
and this American girl
banged on my door
and woke me up.
Or maybe I'm still dreaming?
Uh, you're not still
dreaming. You're wide awake.
Don't let him leave
until he fixes my shower.
He lives downstairs. I don't
want to make it complicated.
Oh, sometimes
the best relationships
are complicated.
Did you forget something?
I did.
Do you guys know each other?
Turns out we do.
See? I told you.
Paris seems like a big city,
but it's really
just a small town.
I'm so happy to see you!
I really wish Gabriel had
told me he had a girlfriend
before I thanked him
with my mouth.
I thought
you just kissed him?
I did.
Your English is as confusing
as your French.
Yeah, I feel stupid.
In both languages.
I really like her.
She likes you, too.
I wouldn't have kissed you
if I knew
you had a girlfriend.
It's okay. You didn't know.
Why didn't you tell me?
I didn't know
you were going to kiss me.
Well, I just thought
that you felt...
Ugh!
Doesn't matter now, so...
Clearly, it was just me,
and I made it all up
in my head, so...
Forget it.
Forget what?
The kiss in your kitchen.
I don't remember.
It must not
have been very good.
It wasn't just you.
I felt it, too.
Good night, Gabriel.
Emily, hi.
Where are you off to
so dressed up?
Oh, I have tickets
to the ballet.
Oh, with Thomas, I presume?
Do you have
a problem with him?
I'm sorry,
but I think he's a snob.
An asshole masquerading
as an intellectual.
I know his type.
Maybe...
Maybe you can't tell
since you're not from Paris.
Well, you're not
from Paris, either.
Sorry, I...
-It's not how I meant it.
-Fine.
I just think
you're wasting your time
on a guy
who doesn't deserve you.
Okay, just one fun drink,
and then we have
to get out of here.
Just one?
She's fun.
She's not supposed
to be that fun.
She's voicing Mother Goose
in a Pixar movie.
Well, it's a good thing
no one's
paying attention here.
Yeah, at home,
she's the good girl,
but here--
She can get away
with everything.
It's just Paris.
It's not some
alternate universe
where rules don't apply.
We don't come to Paris
to be good.
Uh...
Um...
I'm not somebody
who can share a crêpe.
-I need the whole crêpe.
-Emily--
I don't think we should
see each other anymore.
It's not good for any of us.
I was just offering you
a ride home.
A sunrise...
Thank you again
for your help.
I can get myself home.
Emily, have you tasted
this man's coq au vin?
I definitely have not.
I tell you,
when it hit my lips,
I was ready
to propose to him.
I feel like
we've made it pretty clear
that we can't
just be friends.
But we live
on top of each other.
You're proving my point.
So what?
We just stop speaking?
What do we tell Camille?
We don't
tell Camille anything.
We just have to be friendly.
-But not friends?
-Yes.
Can you make me
a list of rules?
Because
it's a little complicated.
Okay, fine.
I'll make it easy.
You go to the market,
I'll go on the tour,
and everybody keeps
their hands to themselves.
Hmm...
Wow, this…
this chicken is...
I told you.
His coq is the best.
-It… it really is delicious.
-Hmm, and so juicy.
Well, since you didn't
get to try my eggplant,
at least
you're enjoying my coq.
Gabriel found a restaurant
he can afford.
Isn't that good news?
The restaurant
isn't in Paris, Emily.
It's in Normandy,
where he's from.
What? He…?
He's moving to Normandy?
You and Camille?
We want different things
right now,
and...
we need to be free
to do them.
What does that mean?
Well, she's not coming
to Normandy,
and I'm not staying
in Paris,
so we will just go
our own ways.
Gabriel!
Hello?
Emily?
I...
I just… I...
I didn't want that
to be the last time
that we saw each other,
and I'm...
I'm gonna miss you so much!
And I...
You said
that you were leaving.
Tell me you didn't feel
everything that I felt.
I can't do this to Camille.
I don't want
to hurt Camille, either.
I… But I can't stop
thinking about you.
About us...
I'm still in love
with Gabriel, Emily.
And I'm afraid
I've lost him.
You haven't.
This is just
such a huge mess.
I know.
And I'm sorry.
I really am.
You know, leek is not
an American vegetable
that hits you
over the head with flavour.
It's subtle.
Elusive.
It's so misunderstood.
What?
Don't laugh at the leek.
Okay, let me show you.
Oh, no, no, no.
You have to cut that bit.
I… I look ridiculous
in this one.
-No, I think you look great.
-Come on.
-It was candid.
-No, no, no. Please, please!
-No.
-Please, delete it. Please.
No, it's my account.
You have to trust me.
-It's my face.
-You have to trust me.
So...
did you get
everything you want?
I'm only in Paris
for a year.
It's always been the deal.
And I don't want us
to start something
that we can't continue.
This you and me…
It's a… It's a fantasy.
It's a...
-A Paris fantasy.
-Hey, hey, hey.
It's not a fantasy to me.
We both know that you're
not moving to Chicago,
and I'm not
staying in Paris.
Then what?
And I'm not going
to fall in love with you
when we have
an expiration date.
You don't text me back
or answer my calls,
and then
you just show up here?
What?
Em, I lost my phone.
I had no way
of contacting you.
I couldn't remember
where you worked.
But I remembered you
did an event at this place.
I'm pretty sure
it's in that suit jacket
of mine you stole.
Oh.
That jacket.
He's the reason.
Yeah, I guess.
Well, it's good
to know the truth...
even if it's hard to watch.
Do you think
you could spare us a table?
It would be my pleasure.
I think I understand your
type a little better now.
English, less complicated...
Yeah, way less complicated.
He doesn't have a girlfriend
I'm also friends with.
It's over.
We're just friends.
And as her friend...
I'm glad
she's with a good guy.
Okay, you need to decide
what you want
and not what's going
to make everyone else happy.
This isn't just
a fun year abroad anymore.
This is your life.
I think I'm staying in Paris
for longer than a year.
Oh. For how long?
I don't know.
Indefinitely. Maybe.
When I came here, Paris
was this fun little detour
that I thought
would be a good story,
but now I think this detour
is where I'm supposed to be,
because my life is here now,
you know.
My friends, my career and...
you.
Emily, I should tell you--
And I just need
to say this, okay,
before I lose the nerve.
I just need to tell you
that the reason
I said I couldn't
be with you, okay,
wasn't Alfie.
Gabriel, I'm--
I made some room,
but I think we're gonna
need another dresser.
Emily.
Hi.
Gabriel asked me to move in.
Oh, wow!
You guys are back together.
Yeah, we wanted to tell you,
but it just happened, so...
That's great.
Yay! Neighbours!
Well, I guess I'll just
see you around, then.